(audience applauding and cheering)
- It's nice to see you again.
- Thanks.
- Yeah.
- And yes,
it's nice to see you
always.
- I know.
We're fans of you,
so we always get so excited when you come.
- And I am a fan of yours.
- Okay, well, I like
this interview already.
So your kids
(audience laughing)
are older than mine.
I heard that you're close to
being a full empty nester.
- I have a colleger.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- As they used to say
when they were little.
- Recent?
- No, she's pretty...
No, she's a junior.
Oh, she's a junior, okay.
- But it feels recent
because I hate it.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- But-
- Get them further away.
- And I have a ninth-grader-
- Oh, okay.
- But I'm holding on
for dear life, just trying
(audience laughing)
to really delay him
as much as possible,
(Kelly and audience laughing)
so he never-
- COVID might've helped.
- So he never leaves,
he never leaves me.
- Oh, my gosh. I know.
I freak out.
I have friends that have
older kids than mine,
and I'm like, I can't imagine.
You feel like you've done your best job,
I assume.
- Totally.
- But like still.
- It's the weirdest, most
antithetical thing, parenting,
because your entire job
is to teach them to fly.
- Yeah.
- And then their actual flight
is the most devastating possible thing
that could happen to you.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
So it feels very unfair
because you're constantly like
against your own challenge
of you know.
No, but I mean, they're, yes,
my one in college loves college,
which is such a blessing.
- Yeah.
- And is thriving
and doing all the things she's
supposed to be doing, and-
- [Kelly] See? You did a great job.
They're gonna be fine.
- I'm trying.
She doesn't know how to drive yet.
She's almost 21.
So we have some areas.
- This is a
generational thing.
This is a-
- Yeah.
- Yeah, even my niece and nephew,
everybody is getting it way later in life.
- Yeah.
- It's not like it was
when we were young.
That was freedom.
- No, I mean, we-
- That was like getting a job,
freedom.
- We knew how to make
Thanksgiving by seventh grade.
- [Both] Yeah.
- We were-
- Your house did. (laughs)
- It was a different time.
- Yeah.
- I mean, no,
it's just, again, we didn't
have, it was different.
We didn't have babysitters.
- Yeah.
- We didn't have all of it.
- [Kelly] Or Uber.
- Or Uber.
- Uber, yeah, yeah.
- No, exactly.
- Yeah.
- But she grew up
in New York City,
so we moved here-
- Ah.
- Just last year for "American Auto,"
and New York City kids do
not ever learn how to drive.
It's obnoxious.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- But.
- They're just not used to it.
- No, they're not used to it, so-
- What was that move like,
going from New York to here?
That's pretty different.
- It's huge. It's a big difference.
I mean, and luckily,
for me, it was the boy.
My girl really was like taking the subway,
and going to tap class,
and doing all kinda things
by herself by-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Eighth grade or so.
- Wow.
- The ninth-grade boy
was a little easier of an adjustment
'cause he still doesn't
always remember his pants
and stuff like that, so.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- I have a boy and a girl as well.
This is true. (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, so I mean,
he's a great student,
(Kelly laughs)
and he's a hard worker,
but he needs a little more oversight,
so it's a little easier
to have him in LA, yeah.
- Okay. So have you been doing anything?
I mean, ninth grade, though,
it's only three more years,
and then-
(Ana whimpers)
I know, no, wait, wait.
(audience laughing)
Have you been doing anything
to mark it, family vacations,
anything fun?
- Well, so that's why
we moved here because I
did commute their entire,
both of their lives for all my work.
After "Saturday Night
Live," I stayed in New York.
I did a lot of theater and I did any TV.
I would just come and go, and
come and go, and come and go.
- Yeah.
- And finally,
"American Auto" was here
and it was so much time.
It was just clear that
I wasn't gonna be able
to like fly home for the weekend.
And so I have been to
like every basketball game
and I have been more of
an active participant
in a great way-
- Present.
- In his life, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then we just went to Spain.
- (gasps) I love Spain.
- It was our first vacation
since COVID, actually.
- Yeah, I'm about to do my
first one and it's in Europe.
I haven't been on a big vacation
in a while like that, yeah.
- Are you taking the littles?
- No, I'm not.
- [Ana] Okay.
- Nope. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
No, I always have the littles.
- Okay, yeah.
- So just this one time
that he has them-
- Sangria.
- And I'm like, oh, my God-
- You're gonna-
What shall I do with my time?
- Yes.
- I will go to Europe
with friends.
- You're gonna go to Europe.
Big old jug-
- Yes.
- [Ana] Jug of sangria.
- Just doing irresponsible things
'cause I can.
- Fantastic.
- (laughs) Yeah.
(audience applauding and cheering)
It's like, it's nice.
And you-
- And the plane.
The plane alone without kids.
- Oh, my god.
- When you're used to flying
with little children.
- I'm so excited-
- It's heaven.
- About my little cubicle-
- A magazine.
- And my little area
on the plane.
- Nobody needs anything.
- I'm so excited.
- I know.
It's the best.
- Yeah, 'cause when you're
in a plane with kids,
you have to make sure
they're not disturbing-
- No,
the whole time.
- The whole plane.
Yes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I heard you do this thing
that's almost like "Holiday," the movie.
You do like a,
you swap houses with people?
- Yeah,
so we are part of like a...
We signed up for this like home exchange,
I would say collective or community,
but then it sounds like I'm in a cult.
I mean, it's like we just...
(Kelly and audience laughing)
Anyway, it's a home exchange community.
- Okay.
- And you pay a fee,
and then it kind of self-filters.
You have to be recommended.
And it's all people who work.
My husband's in advertising.
It's all people who work
in advertising and design.
So usually, someone knows someone
who knows someone kind of a thing.
- Yeah.
- So the creepy factor's
not 100%, and-
- And if they're in design,
their house is probably cool.
- No, it's actually, a lot of times,
I'm like, "Oh, we can't
exchange with them.
Their place is way, way,
(Kelly and audience laughing)
way too nice.
They're gonna be horrified
when they come to our house."
- Oh, my God.
- Yeah, so,
but we've done it a few times.
We do it with an Italian
family and a Spanish family.
- Yeah.
- And it's so cool
because it makes the world so small.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I'll sort of swap.
Usually, the kids are
around the same age range
and we'll set up like just basic stuff,
like, "Oh, the good place for
pizza for kids is this place,
but for grown-ups,
I would just go here."
- The intel
has gotta be great, yeah.
- Yeah.
It's better than like Trip...
I mean, Tripadvisor's great-
- Yeah.
- But it gives you that-
- Hands-on experience.
- It just gives you
that hands-on thing.
- Yeah.
- And then, I mean,
in the Italian one, it was hilarious.
We woke up the first
day there, got settled,
and the Italian kids were in
my house, playing "Fortnite"
on our computer.
(audience laughing)
- And your kids were-
- And my son was playing
Italian "Fortnite"
on their computer.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
You know? And it was
just one of those like...
It just made the world feel really lovely
and small in a nice way.
- It is awesome, though,
when you have kids,
and we're at the beach, and I'm like,
"Bro, why do you have
(Ana laughs)
your iPad right now?"
- Yeah.
- There is an ocean
in front of you.
- An ocean
and air.
- Turn it off.
- Yeah.
- I'm like,
"How did it even get down here?"
- I know.
- I'm like,
"What are you doing?"
- I know, yeah.
- Yes.
(audience applauding and cheering)
You have done "SNL,"
Broadway, so many things,
but is it true that your
greatest achievement
is bargain hunting?
- Oh.
- One of my friends
is great at this.
(audience chuckling)
Are you really great at this?
I'm not good at this.
- You're not?
- No, and I grew up
with no money.
- What about
your Wayfair plug?
- I just...
Well, here's my thing, no.
(audience laughing)
I'm not good at bargaining
like in the sense
of like going out and getting something.
- Okay.
- I'm good
at getting you bargains.
You're welcome.
But I'm not,
(Ana and audience laughing)
I'm not good at like going out,
or like if you go to a flea
market and people are like,
"Oh, you can talk 'em down."
- Oh, yeah.
- Mm.
- No, I'm not good
at that either 'cause I
get shy and embarrassed-
- Oh.
- And I don't want people
to think I'm cheap.
- Yeah, yeah, I just, yeah.
- Right.
So I panic on that, for sure.
- Yes.
- I'll pick up the whole bill
at dinner instead of like argue
over how many Cokes somebody had.
Do you know?
- 100%.
- Okay, that's fine.
- Yes.
- But I get a lot
of dopamine hits from being thrifty,
like so-
- Oh, yeah.
- Like if I find something cheap-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Or if I find, like I
paid for all of our flights
to Europe using points and miles.
- Yeah.
- So, and it was
like the scene from "Homeland"
or like "A Beautiful Mind."
(Kelly laughs)
I'm like swapping, like,
"I can move the Hilton
over to American points, and if I do..."
And my husband's like,
(Kelly and audience laughing)
"Literally, you could
be doing anything else
and making money right now."
But anyway, but I get really,
like the thrill of it's a thrill.
Amazing.
- Yeah.
- And the thrill of the hunt is great,
like finding something
and getting a steal,
and that makes me really excited.
- Okay, so I get this...
My sister once told me.
I had no idea, right?
So I was like an Amazon
Prime member or whatever.
- Yeah.
- And I don't work for them,
so this isn't like a plug.
(audience laughing)
I just mean I didn't know.
And I was paying for birthday parties
and paying for things, like
things that you get for things
just constantly, right?
- Yes, yes.
- And 'cause I'm a working mom,
single, whatever.
- Yes.
- My sister was like, "Hey, by
the way, did you realize..."
I had, this is not a joke, like six mil,
it was like some crazy 6
million points or something
because I used my,
some-
- Amex?
- Amex? Yeah.
- Yes.
- Card or something, and I
was like, "What do you mean?"
So then I proceeded to shop
for like two years for free
on Amazon.
- That's incredible.
And I was like, "What?"
(Ana and audience applauding)
- I salute you.
- And every time I'd say
use my points and it goes zero,
it doesn't matter how much
money you have in life,
it feels good.
- Oh, it feels...
(Kelly and audience laughing)
So here's the best one I ever did.
Okay, so we have a house on Fire island,
which is like a little beach community.
- I've heard of Fire Island.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- A little,
it's a barrier reef island
off the coast of Long Island.
- Yeah.
- Anyway,
a lot of rich people
throw away their stuff
at the beginning of the season,
which makes for really
great bargain hunting.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause they'll clean
out the house 'cause they're preparing
to rent their house or whatever.
So it's great-
- What about those
garage sales?
- There's this...
That's what I'm saying.
- Okay, yeah.
- They don't have a garage sale.
They just put it on their-
- Just free.
- There's trash box things
to keep the deer from eating your trash.
Do you know what
I'm talking about?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That you keep, yeah, for bears
or whatever, yeah, yeah.
- Yes, exactly.
So they put their stuff out.
So one time, one weekend,
I was walking by,
and there was a perfectly
good Nespresso machine.
I already had an Nespresso machine,
which I had gotten
(Kelly and audience laughing)
for my birthday, but a month later,
there was a perfectly
good Nespresso machine.
It looked brand new.
I took it home. I was super excited.
I poured water through it.
It poured straight out the
bottom and all over my floor.
Okay.
- Oh.
- Under-
- You see why it was-
- And I was like, got it.
- Got it, yeah, yeah.
- So I...
(Kelly and audience laughing)
But you know what I did?
I was like, this thing looks new.
So I picked up the phone
and I called Nespresso,
and they're like, "Oh, yeah,
the serial number is new.
I'll send you a new one."
Completely new.
(audience gasps)
So I gave it to my friend, Sally,
for her 40th birthday.
(Kelly gasps)
- Look at that.
(audience laughing)
- Because yes,
(audience applauding)
and the greatest thing
is she's also thrifty, so
I told her the whole story.
She was like so extra excited
that it was trash-picked.
- Yes.
(Ana and audience laughing)
That's thoughtful.
- She trash-picked a
stroller once in Brooklyn,
so yeah.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- Friendship.
- Yeah. (laughs)
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- So explain to everybody,
if they haven't seen it,
what "American Auto" is about.
- [Ana] It's a workplace comedy on NBC-
- Love.
- In the great tradition
of the half-hour workplace comedy.
- Yeah.
- And it's set in the C-suite
of an automotive company, Payne Motors.
And I'm the new female CEO.
I don't know anything about cars.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
And I'm not worried about the fact
that I don't know anything about cars.
So it's a delightful workplace comedy.
It's a bunch of well-meaning
but sometimes completely
misguided executives.
- You wanted to say idiot.
(all laughing)
You were like, "Misguided."
(audience applauding)
- Misguided.
(Kelly laughs)
Let me set up your clip.
Okay, so we have developed this really,
this turd of a car called the
Pika that we're trying to sell
because our stock price is so low
and we're trying to recover.
There's been a whole long season arc
about our company being in deep trouble,
and we're trying to convince
dealers to sell the Pika.
And our idea is that we're
gonna fill this cute, little car
with Pikas, which are
an endangered species.
They look like rabbits.
So we can't...
(audience laughing)
We can't use pikas because
they're endangered,
so instead, they fill it with rabbits.
And I get in the car and
my character, Katherine,
is incredibly phobic about rodents.
So she has a meltdown,
(Kelly and audience laughing)
and then she takes way too many Valium,
and then
(Kelly laughs)
ultimately ends up driving
that car full of rabbits
(laughs) successfully.
(audience laughing)
- Which is just
always a good plan.
(audience applauding)
- Yes.
(Kelly laughs)
- That's when you call your Uber.
All right, everybody, we have a clip.
Here is Ana in "American Auto."
(air whooshing)
(audience applauding and cheering)
- I'm all right.
(rabbits squeaking)
Nope.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
Can't do this. Dori?
Dori, uh, uh, uh, uh,
uh, you're gonna need
to get me something for this.
You're gonna need to get
me something for this.
- Oh, oh, what? Like a poncho?
- Uh, what? No.
No, like a Valium, or a
Xanax, or something strong!
- Well, how am I supposed to find that?
- Well, what is an assistant
for if you can't get me drugs?
Go!
Oh, (beep).
(rabbits squeaking)
(Ana laughs)
(audience cheering)
- Are you actually
into cars at all?
(audience applauding)
'Cause if you were in New
York, did you have a car?
- No.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I mean, we have a Kia, which I love,
but everybody thinks...
It's a black Kia.
And it was the only color available.
I didn't want it 'cause
my husband was like,
"We're gonna get this one.
I'm gonna get it in black."
And I said, "Everyone's
gonna think it's an Uber."
And literally,
(Kelly and audience laughing)
three times a week, somebody
knocks on my window,
(Kelly and audience laughing)
easily.
- I am not your driver.
- Yeah, literally, they're like,
"Hey, something," but so...
- Oh, my gosh.
- Routinely.
- But it's very...
I love the mileage and
it's got butt warmers,
so.
- Okay, ooh.
- Yeah.
- You know what?
- Once you go seat warmer,
you don't go back.
- You don't go back,
and the mileage is bonkers.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
(audience applauding)
- So.
- Okay, everybody, you can
catch "American Auto" Tuesdays
on NBC and streaming on Peacock.